I have been troubled by my belief for many years. I have been influenced by Christianity since I was a child.
Dear God, please bless me in the lottery so that I can control the world.
Then adopt all the cats. Ok, thank you, goodbye!
But after my sister committed suicide at the age of 17, I became an atheist.
Dear God, why are you doing this? You are a jerk, I will leave you now. Goodbye!
Then I came into contact with Buddhism.
Buddha, the Eight Holy Path sounds too dazzling, good, dude.
Finally, I decided to be an agnostic.
Dear alien, or FBI, or my brother, or anyone who is listening to me,
If there is a kind of deep power that I can't understand, it is like a small ant can't understand
Individual employment tax rate on annual statements. Then
I am very willing to recognize my ignorance.
From my efficacious point of view, the generation of the same age as me seems to be less concerned about the practice of doing so.
We don't want to understand at all. We are not encouraged to meditate.
But when we tried to do it, we discovered that God, it is super difficult.
what! so boring! I am very busy!
And I don't really like to organize religious activities. I do not know
How can there be a universal law that applies to everyone? Or when we didn’t even figure out the atomic science
It can explain where people will go after death.
The result came out. We finally found out that we didn’t know anything.
[Super Excited]
In fact, this new study denies what we know.
Everything!
[Super Excited]
We are scientists!
Should I believe in God? If so, which god should I believe?
Should you believe in God in Western tradition?
The one who sat in heaven and could do everything
The one who has been watching my actions? Maybe because he subscribed to me?
Dear God, please bless me in the lottery so that I can control the world and adopt all the cats.
How does she know her fate?
Where is the erase memory key pressed?
what! No electricity, you have to change the battery.
I really want to believe that there is such a god who has been caring for protecting me.
Protect everyone.
But once I think about the terrible things that happen in the world,
I really can't believe that there is such a god.
Is there really an unknown force in the world that guides the world?
Or connect everyone? Is there in the middle?
The transmission of energy?
Really, I really want to believe that there is that kind of thing. But don't misunderstand me,
They are all different.
If you resonate with a religion and make you want to be a better person
Then don’t even think about it. I mean, people should follow their own wishes.
A summary of your life experience can find a kind of
unbreakable faith.
You see, my faith is in my different stages of life.
Constantly changing and developing. And I don't reject this change.
What do you think? I feel sorry after I ask the question.
Or pass this video will make me regret, can I face all kinds of doubts?
Please tell me. I am Anna Akana, I wish you all happy, see you next time!
I am especially grateful to audible for sponsoring this video.
Audible.com is a good online listening audio book website with 180,000 books to choose from.
Cover all types of literary works
I like to listen to audio books because it saves my children -
Little trees
I’m listening to ROOM’s book recently,
It is a story of a brave mother.
This site offers a 30-day free trial
You can go to Audible.com/anna to register and start listening to audio books.
Remember to be Audible.com/anna
Earth Mother Goodbye